hey guys at 7:00 I'm standing outside my
new condo and I'm gonna go in with you
guys for the first time I've just taken
off my shoes and I'm gonna open the door
for the first time since getting it so I
can go on a tour with you now I used to
be in a 5,000 square-foot house like I
built it from scratch on my own and it
was just too big so I sold it and
decided to move into a condo so here we
are I am just happy that everything is
clean I was worried that I guess when
you get a new place you never know what
the the old people are gonna do with it
and thankfully everything so far it
looks like it's clean so that is
definitely a good start so here we are
we go in this is the guest bathroom let
me turn the lights here I am going to
have to change those curtains but
otherwise I got this place because I
like the modern touches so if you look
at the the finishes you've got you know
though the bars there we've got the dark
wood the mirrors are kind of the same so
I like the finishes I like the location
it's super close to my office it's super
close to a lot of action here in Toronto
I'm so happy things are cleaning okay
this is the so this is the den room so
you got the doors this is a pretty small
room I haven't figured out learning to
use it for you but this is the room
maybe a little home office or something
not sure yet but we'll see I'm glad
things are clean moving on this is the
laundry room I think yes
laundry room a little bit of storage
back here storage is always great in a
condo moving on to the kitchen I like
this kitchen because it again it's
modern it's got the the silver handles
it got stainless steel appliances I like
the island behind me here is the kind of
living room and I wanted something that
was really open-concept so I could be
making something in the kitchen and
still watching TV and hanging out I
don't like the kitchen being closed off
and especially in the condo that's the
condos aren't that huge so you want to
make you using your space and I like you
the concept coming this way this is the
master so let's walk in again everything
looks nice and clean which is great the
curtains I'm gonna have to change again
but that's fine
walking here this is the walk-in closet
so not a great size but not a terrible
size at least it is a walk-in I got my
electrical panel here great then the
master bath get some lights going on
here so we've got shower some storage
mirror hello and again it's great that
everything kind of matches and we've got
the same handles everywhere and the dark
wood I love the dark wood and I love the
stainless steel and and the China chunky
handles we'll leave this room for now
I'm gonna go show you the other room
this is just a second room guest room
again I'm gonna have to change those
curtains tons of mirrors on this side
welcome to my place okay let me back up
here this is one of the main reasons why
I've got this this is my living room /
dining room so decent sized space and I
love it because it's a corner unit it's
facing southeast so I'm gonna get a lot
of bright Sun in the morning and if I
look out so you can see here these are
the houses of Toronto and we just had
our first snowfall so you can see that
there are you know snow on top of the
rooftops but looking out here let me see
if I can zoom them a little bit you can
see downtown Toronto view of the CN
Tower and nothing is ever gonna get
built in front of this unit so I'm gonna
enjoy this huge nice view every day when
I wake up I've got this balcony here so
I can go out and enjoy if I want but for
me natural light is super important and
I love that there are
you know hot lights I guess that's
pretty standard for for condos let me
walk into the other room too I can see
you I can feel myself here so I love
natural light I've always loved natural
light in my office we had these
fluorescent bulbs that were put in there
before and I had to rip them all out
because they gave me a headache and
every place that I go to needs to have
huge windows because I don't know
natural light seems to inspire me I
can't work in a room where I don't have
tons of light around me so this is my
place hopefully you guys like it I
haven't moved anything as you can
obviously see again I'm just glad that
things are not all destroyed and
everything is looking pretty clean
throughout the weeks maybe I'll do some
quick updates and show you as I'm moving
something or buying new stuff for the
place a little bit of a personal touch
so thank you guys welcome to my new
place if you guys liked the video give
it a thumbs up if you want to see more
about what I'm doing here leave a
message and I'll see you guys soon